it's just gone at 15 GMT and we start
with some breaking news from the
occupied West Bank where at least four
Israelis have been shot and killed near
the illegal settlement of Ellie the
Israeli Army says the suspects opened
fire on a restaurant and then a petrol
station before engaging them in a gun
battle now this comes a day after six
Palestinians were killed in an Israeli
attack on the Janine refugee camp let's
go live now to our correspondent Imran
Khan he's standing by for us in occupied
East Jerusalem Imran Fullerton a little
bit more on what happened
well what I can tell you is that the
Israeli ambulance services confirming
that those four people have now actually
died they died on the spot uh in that
near that illegal settlement of ili in
the occupied West Bank the Israeli Army
have released their initial
investigation saying that the
Palestinian who carried out the terror
attack that stay words not mine at a gas
station uh near the settlement of it
arrived by car and first targeted a
restaurant now he opened fire at that
restaurant and then targeted at the gas
station at one point an armed civilian
shot dead one of the Palestinian
attackers while the second attacker
actually stole a running vehicle and
fled the area the Israeli military have
added that the Israeli soldiers have now
thrown up a Manhunt and they put up
roadblocks and checkpoints to try and
apprehend that suspect now this is a
very serious attack but it does come a
day after the events in Janine where
Palestinians work ill in a raid that
actually used helicopter gunships
something that we haven't seen in the
occupied West Bank for about 20 years
now it's very difficult to figure out
what kind of motive there may have been
for this attack but the timeline
suggests that it may well have something
to do with those Janine attacks but
until somebody claims responsibility we
don't know now in terms of
responsibility we are seeing gun attacks
like this and they seem to be taking
place
um by people who aren't really
affiliated with any particular group but
are looking for Revenge when it comes to
the things that they've seen go on in
the occupied West Bank now this is a
moving story uh far right Minister Beth
Modric and the foreign minister who's
very controversial who's a security
minister are on the way to that West
Bank settlement so we're going to be
hearing from them shortly absolutely as
you say it's a very serious attack and
the Israelis will be taking it seriously
and it's bound to provoke some sort of
response
um
well prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
has actually convened a meeting a
consultation to figure out what steps
they take next he'll be taking advice
from security officials from security
advisors plus the police and the Army
now remember
the occupied West Bank comes under
Israeli military control it's not
subject to any kind of Civilian control
so the Army have a lot of leeway when it
comes to mounting operations but there
is talk of this a large-scale operation
within the occupied West Bank it's
something that the right wing of this
Coalition the far right are actually
calling for they want a decisive
operation within the occupied West Bank
that's something that the police and the
Army have resisted uh so far but more
and more attacks like this take place
those calls grow ever louder
anything from the Palestinian leadership
so far Imran
not yet it's far too early for to tell
what they're going to be able to say we
do know that in the past they've
remained fairly silent when it comes to
attacks like this uh simply they don't
want to kind of alienate anybody but
it's likely when it comes to something
like this as serious as this they will
react and we'll probably get that in the
coming hours
okay everyone can't bring us all the
latest there on that shooting in the
occupied West Bank which has killed four
Israeli near a settlement